زفاف بحضور تامر حسني يتحول لجدل عنوانه
خراب بيوت فما القصه
[موسيقى]
في الشعبيه الكبيره تامر حسني نشر بوست
عبر حساباته على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بارك فيها لمديره اعماله هاله عمر بمناسبه
زواجها وضح مكانتها الكبيره عنده بسبب
دفاعها الشديد عنه منذ الصغر وازاي
اشتغلوا مع بعض وعبر كمان عن اخلاصها
وتفانيها الكبير في شغلها لحد هنا البوست
عادي جدا وقد يكون بوست جميل ولقع اعجاب
واشاده كبيره من جمهور نجم الجيل عن
تقديره لفريق عمله واعطائه دايما الفرص
للشباب
[موسيقى]
اللي حصل بعد كده ان البوست ده تحول لجدل
كبير خلال ساعات والسبب اسطوري نشرتها
طليق تامر حسني بسمه بوسيل واللي كتبت
فيها
[موسيقى]
وبين كل الاراء دي هاجم البعض بسمه بوسيل
وتسائلوا على السبب وراء عدم تواصلها
المباشر مع تامر حسني
واستمرارها دايما في نشر ما يخص حياتهم
الشخصيه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وفي فريق ثاني شاف زاويه مختلفه من القصه
وهي ان العلاقه المثاليه بعد الطلاق واللي
تصدرت للجمهور بسبب ظهور تامر حسني وبسمه
بوسيل مؤخرا في صور بتجمعهم في عيد ميلاد
بنتهم ومباركتها ليه على الاعمال الجديده
هي مجرد صوره وهميه وبتبان الحقيقه في
المواقف اللي زي دي
[موسيقى]
اما عن جليل المغربيه فانتهزت الفرصه
لتبرقه نفسها بعد محاصرتها الشائعات لفتره
طويله عن ارتباطها بتامر حسني وقت زواجه
والهجوم الشديد عليها
[موسيقى]